Tell me,
have you ever seen somebody else's child
behave appallingly in a supermarket?
(Audience murmurs)
Did you secretly blame the mum
for her lack of control?
Or did you even feel a little bit smug
because you knew that your child
would never behave like that?
For 10 long years I was that mum
you were staring at.
And those stares hurt.
They made me feel
I was failing as a parent.
And it wasn't just other people
who I didn't know in shops
that would stare and that were judging me.
That judgment came
from friends and family,
from health care professionals,
from school staff and from social workers.
Being judged consistently
for such a long period of time
diminished my self-esteem
and my self-confidence.
It left me feeling crushed and broken.
It had a really overwhelming impact
on my ability to be able
to do anything well,
including my ability to be
the best parent possible
to my three children
at exactly the time they really needed me
to be right at the top of my game.
Now, my middle child, Toby,
he's gorgeous.
He is funny, he's boisterous.
He loves people.
But he also has a profound
intellectual disability.
He's autistic and he can't talk.
And that means that, sadly,
Toby's also had to get used to
being judged and stared at as well.
Just think what a scary place
the world must be for Toby.
And he can't even ask any questions
to try and help him make sense
of what's going on around him.
When somebody can't talk,
often, the only effective way
they have of communicating
is through their behavior.
And throughout Toby's childhood,
the more frightened he became,
the more frightening
his behavior became as well.
For those ten years,
our family lived with terrifying,
violent and challenging behavior,
with somebody getting hurt
nearly every single day.
Now Toby had a fantastic team
of specialists around him,
but nobody knew how to help.
Staff had not had any training
in anxiety-led challenging behavior
and there were so few, if any, services
that had been developed
to support families like ours.
And here we are, nearly 20 years later
and nothing's changed.
Instead of getting the essential help
and urgent support these families need,
they are instead being repeatedly
and wrongfully blamed, shamed and judged
for their children's anxiety-led behavior.
And they're also being told
that they're being too soft
and that they're spoiling their child.
Throughout all those times,
everyone was urging me to parent Toby
harder and stricter and more firmly.
I followed their advice to the letter,
but Toby's behavior got worse, not better.
Of course it did.
I can see that now.
He was a frightened
and distressed little boy.
He needed love and kindness.
Being harsh and strict
was never going to work.
But I didn't know that then.
So I really tried
to follow all that advice.
Everyone was singing
from the same song sheet,
and the message was loud and clear,
that I was an incompetent parent
who was failing my child
and badly letting down
his brother and sister.
Those years were incredibly tough
and all that judgment
made it so much harder.
A little bit of kindness
and an attempt at understanding
could have gone to so far.
Over time, in the absence
of any professional help,
I eventually developed my own
wild and wacky strategies
that sometimes worked.
However, people then
were often as bewildered
by my own decidedly odd behavior
as they were by Toby's,
particularly at hospital appointments.
Now, hospitals are very controlled
and structured environments
staffed by highly trained professionals.
That's absolutely everything
that Toby is not.
Toby's noisy and he's playful
and he's chaotic and he's disruptive.
It was always going to be a disconnect.
The other thing about Toby
is he's incredibly hospital-savvy.
He can spot a healthcare
professional at 100 paces,
and you're not always his favorite people.
He also knows things about hospitals
that you don't know.
He knows that if he's halfway down
a really long hospital corridor,
if he shouts at the top of his voice,
it's going to create magnificent echoes
and people are going to react.
Almost every time
within seconds of arriving at a hospital,
people were giving us a wide berth
and they were already rolling their eyes.
Now, keeping Toby safe and happy
in a hospital isn't easy.
But if I failed, people could get hurt
and equipment broken.
So the stakes were high.
I was constantly on hyper alert,
ready to leap in,
to distract or divert
if things looked a bit tricky.
And it was essential that I was able
to communicate with Toby
in ways that I knew he'd have
the best chance of understanding.
Unfortunately, there wasn't always time
to explain to people
what I was doing and why.
So if you wanted to take Toby's blood
or to do his blood pressure,
I might thrust my arm out like this
and ask you to pretend
to do it to me first.
Because that way,
Toby has a better chance
of understanding what's going on,
so he's going to be
more likely to cooperate.
Toby also understands things much better
if they're sung to him.
So if you need to listen to his chest
and he needs to lift his T-shirt up
to let you be able to do it,
I might have to tell him like this:
(Singing) Where is Toby's tummy?
Where is Toby's tummy?
Show it to the doctor.
(Applause)
Thank you.
Toby isn't naturally compliant,
but he loves playing games.
So at the end of an appointment,
if Toby is far too happy
sitting on your floor
and emptying all your cupboards
to want to stand up and leave,
I might have to play
"Where is Toby's face?"
Now, I play this by cupping my hands
like this in face shape
and putting it all over the room,
saying things like,
"Is that Toby's face?
Where is Toby's face?
Has anybody seen Toby's face?
Oh, could that be Toby's face?"
Eventually he'll cotton on
to what I'm doing,
he’ll burst out laughing,
he'll stand up,
he'll lean his hands
into my face and great.
Except that, if it's a really bad day,
we may still have to perform
the entire “hooray dance”
before we can leave you in peace.
Now, by now,
the look on the face
of the average clinician
is one of sheer horror and fear.
(Laughter)
And there's a clear assumption
that I've lost the plot and gone bonkers.
The very worst thing that can happen next
is if that clinician decides
to try to take over.
And ...
Because they obviously can't believe
I know what I'm doing.
That has meant that sometimes
Toby's been physically manhandled
out of the room
while he and I are both
being told off really loudly.
That's almost exactly
what's guaranteed to frighten Toby
into the worst type of behavior possible.
Sometimes we had a fantastic experience.
We've met some great people
who've been really happy
to join in and play along.
It's remarkable how well
a game of hide and seek
can lend itself to assessments
of cognition, communication skills,
mobility and even Toby's breathing.
But whenever I've really felt
judged in those situations,
all I've wanted to do is to run away
as fast and as far as I can
out of your office.
Now, when I'm feeling like that,
it's almost impossible for me to open up
and share with you my real concerns
about Toby's health,
which means that's going to make
your job much harder
in being able to assess him
and to come up with treatment options,
which of course is going to impact on Toby
and his long-term outcomes and well-being.
Being judgmental really can be
the starting place of health inequalities.
But being judgmental is so easy.
When you judge people
who already feel vulnerable,
you're only ever going to make us feel
more ashamed, more rejected,
and more unworthy.
Kindness is so important.
It can make such a big difference.
Kindness is powerful
and it really can bring out
the best in all of us.
But I've got another
favorite word: curiosity.
When we stay curious,
we keep asking those "why" questions,
which helps us to build bridges
towards better understanding.
When we stay curious,
it keeps our hearts and our minds open,
which helps to prevent us
forming those judgments.
If ever you see me with Toby
and my behavior's looking a bit off,
the very best question
you can possibly ask me is
"Do you need any help?
And if so, what can I do?"
Eventually, we were referred
to a fantastic team
who totally understood
why young people like Toby can develop
these anxiety-led behaviors.
Dr. Helen Simmons and David Smith.
They were there for us, they listened,
they just understood.
They just got it.
And never once did they make me feel
ashamed, blamed or judged.
I was so excited that first day
that David was due to come to our house
and I couldn't wait to ask him
that all-important question,
"So, David, how are we going
to change Toby's behavior?"
David put his cup of tea down.
He looked at me.
He took in a deep breath and then
he dropped a bombshell.
"No, Yvonne, I'm not here
to change Toby's behavior.
I'm here to change yours."
"What?"
I was not happy, I was horrified.
It sounded like the same old, same old
blame judgment all over again.
But it wasn't.
What he was showing me
is that I had to change first.
So ...
I had to unlearn almost everything
I thought I knew about parenting.
What I learned was about anxiety
and exactly why Toby’s behavior
became so difficult,
because anxiety made him so terrified.
I learned that when he was lashing out,
what he was really trying to do
was to scream out for help
because he felt so frightened
and the world was so confusing
and he needed help.
I learned that when he had hurt me,
it wasn't because he hated me.
It was because he trusted me
more than anybody else in the world
to be able to offer him that help
that he so badly needed.
So up until then,
I had gone up and up and up
in terms of being stricter
and harsher and firmer
in the way I parented Toby,
just like everybody had told me to.
I thought I'd tried everything.
I didn't think there was anything left.
Helen and David showed me
that there was an entirely
different direction
and I could go down
and down and down as well.
So my parenting became more loving,
more understanding,
more collaborative and kinder.
It changed everything.
Toby responded brilliantly,
and it was like watching magic happen.
Toby is now 28.
He's incredibly happy.
He's doing so well
and things are really good.
I now know that it was never
about Toby's behavior.
It was always about trying to find ways
to help Toby feel safer
and less frightened
in a world that often seemed
confusing to him.
I now run Newbold Hope.
It's a parent-led organization
devoted to teaching parents
and professionals
how to move children
with anxiety-led behavior
towards happier times.
So far through our work,
we know of over 2,000 children
who've successfully achieved this.
We know from research
that our prison population
is significantly overrepresented
by adults who have ADHD
or who have a learning disability
or who are autistic.
But it doesn't have to be like this.
For decades, we've been giving
parents the wrong advice,
and then we've been blaming them
when it goes even more wrong.
If instead we can step in early enough
and provide parents with the strategies,
the support, the skills
and the confidence they need,
they really can change the course
of their child's life.
But this is not a parental
competence issue.
Far from it.
This group of parents
have taught me so much
and shown me how much can be achieved
with tenacity, true courage,
hope and unconditional love.
These parents,
their parenting skills
are already at ninja level
and they've helped me to realize
that all that time long ago, so were mine.
If you see something
that doesn't quite make sense,
there may still be a clear logic
as to what they're doing
and why they're doing it.
Please don't judge.
Please stay curious
and please keep asking
those "why" questions.
Because that's how you can help
somebody like me feel valued,
understood and included.
And let's be honest,
isn't that what the NHS is all about?
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)